اهلا بك واهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه العربيه
نتواجد داخل مجمع صلاه الحج والعمره
التابع لمطار الملك عبدالس الدولي هنا
بجده استعدادا لمغادره 229 مواطن هندي بعد
ان اتوا عبر عمليات الجهه قامت بها
السلطات السعوديه من ميناء بورت سودان الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بجده هذه هي هذه
هي الرحله الرابعه الخاصه بعمليات اجلاء
الرعايه او المواطنين الهنديين حتى
يستعدوا للمغادره الى بلدانهم عبر الطائره
321 التابع للخطوط الهنديه
سوف يصلون الى مدينه
بنغالير من مطار الملكه بجده الى مدينه
بنجلورور الهنديه وهذه هي الرحله الجلاب
الرابعه بعد ان قامت سوره السعوديه
بالفعل هذه الصور الخاصه وحصريه كما نشاهد
الان وصول او اكتمال عدد الرعايه وهم
عددهم 229 مواطن هندي تم انهاء كافه
اجراءات السفر الخاصه بهم استعدادا
للمغادره عبر مطارات جده من المتوقع وصول
الطائره بعد عشر دقائق من الان العدد
الكلي لكافه الرعايه الهنود الذين تم
اجلائهم من مطار جده عبر عبر 4 رحلات هم
عددهم الف ومائه واربعه وثمانين شخص بهذه
الرحله على متنها
229 تم دخولهم او تم منحهم تاشيرات
استثنائيه من قبل المديريه العامه
للجوازات القطاعات الحكوميه
ومسنين وتبدو حالات الاعياء والتعب عليهم
بالطبع وبالتالي هناك جهود انسانيه لسرعه
انهاء هذه الاجراءات سلطان تحدثت معهم عن
طبيعه ما واجهوه من صعوبات اثناء الانتقال
بالفعل يعني قبل خذ هذه التفاصيل هنالك
معاناه كبيره عاشوا تفاصيلها هؤلاء
الرعايه الهنود هنالك في الخرطومه وحتى في
الولايات التابعه للخرطوم وكذلك اثناء
عمليات الاجلاء الاجلاء من الخرطوم وصولا
الى مدينه بورتسودان وتحديدا الى ميناء
بورتسودان لاستقلال السفن البحريه الملكيه
السعوديه وصولا الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه بجده وبعد ذلك تم تقديم كافه
الخدمات والتشكيلات الخاصه بهم وعلى سبيل
المثال ايضا التحدث انه تم منح هؤلاء
الرعايه تاشيره استثنائيه لمده شهر حتى
يستطيع هؤلاء الرعايه بعد وصولهم الى جده
انهاء كافه اجراءات السفر الخاصه بهم من
قبل حكوماتهم وكذلك من قبل السلطات
السعوديه استعدادا لعودتهم الى بلدانهم
فيما يتعلق بالرعايه او المواطنين الهنود
نتحدث انه
1184 شخص مع هذه الرحله سوف يكون قد
غادروا مدينه جده بعد عمليات الجاليه تمت
الايام الماضيه ضمن المتوقع انه يوم غدا
وتحديدا في تمام الساعه الرابعه عصرا ان
تكون هنالك رحله اجلاء اخرى
لمواطنين الهنود استعدادا لمغادره مدينه
جده الى بلدان سوف تقول سوف يقلها هؤلاء
الهنود طائره من نوع ايرباص 321 عددهم 229
شخص سوف رحله تستغرق قرابه 14 ساعه من
مدينه جده الى مدينه بن جلور الهنديه ايضا
التحدث انه تواجده اليوم هنا عدد من
الممثلين وزاره الخارجيه وكذلك العاملين
او الموظفين بمطارات جده حتى يتسنى لهم
التسهيل وانهاء كافه اجراءات الخاصه بلا
الرعايه استعدادا لمغادرتهم مدينه جده الى
مدينه بانجرور الهنديه كما نوهنا تبقى على
وصول الطائره قرابه عشره دقائق سوف نواكب
عمليه تصعيد هؤلاء الرعايه على متن هذه
الطائره وحتى مغادرتهم مدينه الجده
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات